this video is made possible by brilliant
dog if you live in the northern
hemisphere right now you might have
noticed that it's really rather hot in
the UK we're experiencing a weeks-long
heatwave so severe that when it rained
recently it was greeted with jubilation
in England in Sweden a surge of
wildfires has occurred including more
than a dozen inside the Arctic Circle
where temperatures of topped 30 degrees
and in Japan an unprecedented heat wave
has killed more than 65 people in a
single week it's all but impossible to
sleep horrible to work outside and the
land itself is shriveling up so why is
this happening well as always seems to
be the case there are three main cause
wait no no no no no not yet cause number
one the Atlantic
more specifically the ocean's surface
temperature the surface temperature in
the North Atlantic varies in a complex
fashion every day but underneath that
variability there's a seesaw pattern if
you look at the average monthly
temperature in the Atlantic over several
decades you see this oscillation between
warmer than average and colder than
average temperatures this is called the
Atlantic multidecadal oscillation or amo
and it's caused by the huge ocean
circulation known as the a Mach as well
as surprisingly clouds I'll leave a link
below to a paper if you're interested in
fact every time you see a number on the
screen that's a reference in the
description whether the Atlantic is in a
warm or a cool phase has a huge impact
on parts of the climate like hurricane
formation Arctic sea ice cover and
global temperatures and right now the
amo is in a very positive phase meaning
that the Atlantic is really warm
compared to normal that has a direct
effect on the continents surrounding the
Atlantic with lots more thermal energy
in the northern hemisphere warming
Europe and North America and making
Africa and Europe wetter while making
North America drier wait what the UK
resembles Tatooine right now
incidentally it might like the video I
did about the planets in star wars
well the relationships presented in
these papers show what happens on
average so on average in the past when
the Atlantic has been warmer than normal
Europe has been wetter than normal what
the average response doesn't account for
is the effects of other climate
phenomena and variability on the weather
such as cause number two the jet stream
being particularly weak the jet stream
is a narrow band of fast-moving air that
circles the North Pole
ten kilometers up typically between
about 50 and 60 degrees north it's
caused by the temperature difference
between the pole and the equator
combined with the rotation of the earth
and it's a major factor in what weather
we get in the middle attitudes at the
moment the Jetstream is particularly
weak meaning that the air in the jet is
moving slower than normal or so that the
me and as we see in the jet stream
aren't moving from west to east as fast
as normal because the jet stream marks a
boundary between colder polar air and
warmer temperature if meanders in the
jet stream stay put for a while that
means that regions south of the jet
stream experience warmer than average
temperatures for a long time and
conversely regions north of the jet
experience colder than average
temperatures for a long time the UK and
Scandinavia as well as lots of other
places I didn't mention are all south of
the jet stream and have been for a while
high pressure systems have been sat on
top of these places and refused to budge
that means the colder air and moisture
struggles to get in and alleviate the
hot dry conditions on the flipside
Iceland for example has had its greatest
wettest summer since 1914
that's because Iceland has been on the
other side of the jet stream sitting
further north amongst the persistently
cold temperatures
so Iceland has been cold and wet the
lucky bastard so what caused the jet
stream to be so weak and stationary well
that's quite possibly reason number
three global warming the world is warmer
now than it was before the Industrial
Revolution warming faster than any
natural cycle allows for and that
warming is directly attributable to
human activities notably the release of
gases like carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere there is no debate the
science is unequivocal
if you dispute any of those facts then
you are wrong the globe isn't warming
evenly however due to a phenomenon known
as Arctic amplification the poles are
warming faster than the rest of the
planet which reduces the equator to pole
temperature gradients and because the
jet stream is fed by that temperature
gradient this results in a weaker jet
stream with bigger meanders and the
bigger the meanders in the jet stream
theory tells us that the
more slowly they're gonna move around
the earth so we get persistent weather
patterns like Japan and the UK and
Iceland are experiencing as with all
weather events it is nigh on impossible
to directly attribute a particular event
to global warming these conditions could
well have occurred in an atmosphere
without a single molecule of
anthropogenic origin but what we're
observing at the moment certainly
matches what we would expect to see in a
planet that has undergone global warming
and apart from the weaker Jetstream and
persistent associated high pressure
systems the warming caused by these
local short-term weather systems gets
added on top of the decades-long pattern
of global warming we've seen to give
record temperatures in fact the weak
Jetstream and warm Atlantic also
occurred together in 1976 when the UK
had a record-breaking heat wave which is
now regarded as a yardstick event this
current weather is the most severe heat
wave the UK has seen since then and
monthly average temperatures are higher
in some parts the country now than they
were in 1976 so thanks to global warming
extreme events are getting that bit more
extreme and research indicates that
there'll be more frequent to this summer
in the northern hemisphere is a good
example of what climate change is
probably going to look like this century
when factors come together such as a
warm Atlantic and a wheat jet stream the
additional heat trapped in the Earth's
system by anthropogenic emissions will
take what would have been a big weather
event and make it an extreme one highs
will get higher and as we saw this
winter with the beast from the east you
might want to watch my video about that
the lows will get lower in some places
too but the net effects will be trending
towards a warmer on average climate so
when will this current heat wave end in
the UK well where there's notoriously
difficult to predict long-range
forecasts from the UK Met Office
indicate that the summer isn't going to
cool off significantly by mid to late
August the high pressure system just
isn't budging most likely it's going to
be uncomfortably warm with a few cooler
days until September and then of course
the weather will have to change because
you know seasons but weather prediction
is incredibly difficult especially when
looking more than about a week ahead so
this may well turn out to be wrong for
the time being keep hydrated avoid the
central line check on elderly neighbors
and if you
can enjoy the Sun responsibly this video
was sponsored by brilliant org if you're
interested in how the world works you
should check out their expertly curated
courses on science and maths including
the physics of the everyday in this
course you'll get hands-on with problems
about nuclear power the Coriolis effects
in hurricanes and high pressure systems
like we've been talking about in this
video
brilliant is so well put together and
I've recently had sub subscribers get
back to me saying they've really enjoyed
doing their courses
as have I so if you'd like to join them
and the brilliant community worldwide
then hit the link in the description
that's brilliant org forward slash Simon
Clark and if you wanted the first 200
people to do so then you'll get 20% off
your premium and your subscription
thanks to brilliant for sponsoring this
video and thank you for watching it I
hope I was able to provide a little bit
more detail than just it was the jet
stream that did it Lowell if you did
enjoy it please do leave a comment down
there in the comments section I would
love to do more videos on atmospheric
topics and I basically I just don't know
if people would watch them it's my forte
it's what I know the most about
I'd like to make more videos about it
but I could do with a bit of feedback on
this so if you enjoyed the video do drop
a like leave a comment check out the
references in the description and I'll
see you in the next one thank you again
for watching